i want to speak to your point devil's
advocate on myself um because you said
it's not attractive it's not a good look
i will say that as women we have to pick
a lane and we can't unlike you get into
another lane at 40. you kind of made
your bed right now women can adopt
and that's possible but to have your own
child if you've committed your life to
career and you're in making money
building your wealth just like you have
yeah at this point somebody who's been
on the same track as you yes as a woman
we do not have the same ability to jump
be like you know what actually i want to
have some some kids i don't have three
kids i have 40 you can't do that exactly
you can't do that so it it for me i'm 28
i feel overwhelmed by the pressure of
figuring out if i want to focus on my
career
or
settle down and have kids because it's
not something i want right now but i
don't have 10 years to figure it out i
don't you're bringing up some very valid
points right here and ultimately this is
what we're talking about is
yeah we're talking dating relationships
age gaps but
it's also different for a guy and a girl
like i've been able to focus on my
career do my thing
pivot take on additional things not even
worry like well i've got to have kids
immediately nobody's going why aren't
you married yet well my name is my mom
is like adam holland yeah of
exactly
but
you said that you i have to make choices
yeah so i have to pick my priorities a
woman to have a career you're 28 you're
looking at your clock you have some sort
of clock ticking who was i talking with
did it was it you i don't know it said
like at 30
that clock is ticking like the scene and
uh my cousin vinnie you remember the
scene you know that scene haven't seen
it holy [ __ ] my cousin vinnie marissa
told me she's like baby my clock is
[ __ ] ticking over here okay but you
you've made a conscious decision all
right i'm so is this still an active
decision you're making your life kill it
in my career find a man settle down what
about women your age like these are
conversations that you guys have career
versus
especially performers
which both of you guys are yes um
as a dancer
you have a limited window already yeah
to be a dancer because you're like an
athlete yes by age 30 something yes even
less and then if you get pregnant in the
middle of that you're done you're done
early that's it yeah but if by the time
you finish dancing then you start trying
to have a kid then you're late to the
party okay and it's not like even if i
decided you know what i am ready i have
to find the guy first oh yeah and i am
actively working at that okay working at
it very difficult sometimes it tells me
you're going to be okay with that that's
very nice of you but listen in miami
it's it's hard out here that's right a
lot of dudes haven't even been able to
get second dates so and you grew up in
miami i did and you went to new world
you grew up in miami south miami so
jenny said that the oldest guy that was
your oldest age gap on average what
would you say is there a significant age
so my thing but i'm somebody who's not
just looking to have fun like right like
i've already been there done that but i
i personally feel you don't know
what
unless you try right so like i've dated
guys younger than me i've dated guys
older than me i've dated guys my age
they're all very much so different
you've dated guys younger than you yeah
how much younger uh two to three years
really yeah how'd that work out it did
it i obviously did i know but none of
them none of them did work out what was
it just like you were 24 and they were
23 or 21
yeah well i was 23 he was 21. something
okay but um but yeah what what it's the
experience like people get so caught up
on labeling on on dates on time frames
on this like you just gotta live your
life i've dated 40 year olds who acted
like 21 year olds and i've been dating
21 years old
it's your life experiences i agree
what's the what's the uh oldest you oh
the age gap
eight years eight years it felt right
that felt good in terms of like where
they were in life because they're you
have to date older to get a man who's
maybe considering being in the same
place you are biologically
a 28 year old yeah
they say seven years is the golden
number well between a woman there's
actually a formula
it's actually half your age plus seven
are you familiar with this so if i'm 40
half my age 20 plus 7 is 27 i need to be
looking somewhere around 27 years old
and what about us what's our what's our
formula
uh double your age minus seven i think
it's just sort of a uh really i mean
that's just the the i've always heard
seven is the golden number seven years
ago from a woman to a man yeah okay when
is it weird though
when it when it's too old
yeah like you said you're caught up with
thank you eric you're not caught up on
labels and just live your life okay
21 year old dating a 60 year old is that
creepy yes
because that happens in miami i mean a
lot of them are sugar babies i feel like
i've seen so many of these things on
tick tock they're like we're just in
love and they're like but it's a point
where you're talking about like are you
talking about real love are you talking
about sugar daddies are you talking
about
in the moment one night jenny i don't
like labels
on this i know but no but you're talking
about love like he's clearly not looking
for love like you know
i mean it just depends pretty easy to
love that girl right there do you know
her personally no but she looks very
lovable and you're again basing
everything off of physical appearances
okay so is leo
he's at 25 he's like you know what any
sign of a crow's feet out
i don't know if it's that
so what is it
they probably go hey is this something
serious or am i are we in this okay at
what point in a relationship do you give
the like all right what are we doing
here it depends on how old you are i
think also
for me i'm not like i'm not i'm not just
dating somebody to date them for a
couple months like i'd be like how many
months in do you say do you give them
the talk three months three months say
three two so you'll hook up you'll have
a good time you have a great time to go
to the bars date but three months in
you're gonna all right at this point
what is happening right now yeah but i
feel like as women as you get older and
you've dated enough you know what you
want very quickly you set the line from
jump like the first date you're like
i'm not here for play play like you say
that on a first date i do i mean i don't
date that much but when i go out on a
date like i'm like uh whatever like
clara how do i say that like i'm gonna
talk clear like i'm gonna talk straight
up you're gonna be very clear yeah
you're gonna be clear with your
intentions right now if when i was
younger i didn't i didn't send any
boundaries i'm like okay where are we
going what are we doing let's go
you know but as you get older and you
know what you want because you've
already had experience there is a fine
line with that jenny so um on new year's
uh i was out i'm totally single i had a
like literally a buddy's like hey you
adam this girl uh julie uh you guys are
gonna make out on midnight i was like
okay
and like look at the girls like okay
that's a very good friend yeah very good
great wingman so whatever we have a new
year's kiss all good whatever we hang
out one more time other than new year's
one like literally we had like lunch
he's like hey i'm in your neighborhood
cool whatever
um
i
look quite frankly during the week i'm
focused as hell like i'm not i'm not
worried about what's julia whatever i'm
just doing my thing i hit her up on the
weekend and i was like hey how are you
how's your week she goes why are you
texting me
i go oh what's your reasoning for
texting me
i say oh i need a reason to text you
she goes listen i'm not looking for just
like small talk banter like i need to
know if this is going somewhere or not
i'm like we've hung out twice that's too
that's too much too much
and i sent you know what i sent her you
need a chance to get to know somebody
how do you how can you propose a deal
before you even know what this is 100
you know what i sent her you know the
picture of homer simpson like going back
into the bushes you've seen this thing
before no the gift pull up homer simpson
get bushes
this is what i sent her and she goes
thank you i'm glad to know where you
stand she thanked me well she had the
whole conversation with herself
basically pull this up she decided what
you want this is literally what i text
her
bye yeah that was me just being like
yeah that's a little red flag i don't
need to make a i don't need to establish
anything on the first date but i do like
to know what the options are
is there a door for some are you in a
place where you could consider i don't
need to know right now
but if it's something that's on the
table for you or not
okay
back to back to eric she's laughing
jenny wants to say something go jenny
jenny
let it out judge somebody judge somebody
it's not judgmental it's just different
live limitless
live limitless right now no restrictions
on this conversation it's communication
okay like there's some people that
literally just like they know they want
to play so why are you gonna continue a
day if you know that person just wants
to play now if there's look i don't know
let's see where it goes okay let's see
where it goes but some people are
clearly like i just want to have fun
that's it right if a guy would never say
that but they never say that they don't
never know what guy's like look i'm
really not looking for any on a first
date look i'm not going to do on their
tinder profiles they say what i'm not
looking for anything serious hookups
only
they say that i've seen so many of that
and then what they're they're right left
i'm just saying but some girls just like
all right even if i am not looking for a
relationship the fact that you write
that on your profile just doesn't turn
off do she move it's just dude um
because you don't know me what if i am
the love of your life why are you saying
that i mean i appreciate it it's
straight up you're not wasting time
people waste so much time it's time is
money
especially for women according to amber
well not as you increase your eggs
at what age do women's biological click
clock start ticking well what age but
nowadays you can freeze your eggs so
it's a little bit different not that you
can stir them yourself that is true they
usually say like there's also
your late 30s early 40s
is yeah you're into the risk you went to
the risk zone
you
yeah i everybody keeps telling me like
you have a little more time every older
woman they're like you're you're they're
like you're 28 you're you have a little
more time that's what i get oh i just
thought of a story crazy story one of
the craziest stories i've ever had in my
life
so
it's not a secret that my best friend
one of my best friends is the guy chris
humphries that married kim kardashian
do you know this okay i was in in the
wedding i walked chloe down the aisle
the whole thing i lived at kim's house
for a week i mean we're they were going
all over the world in a jet to mexico
the whole the whole freaking thing
and i remember how like because kim is
my age kim is 40 now okay and chris is
actually five years younger and i
remember having a conversation with her
i was like because i'm pretty blunt i
was like i remember being in mexico at
joe francis's house randomly the guy
that created girls gone wild they're
like good friends with him
and
i said uh because they got engaged very
quickly and then they set the date and i
just sort of
you know
in passing was like
things are moving pretty quick here kim
she goes yeah yeah i'm 30. uh
i gotta move quickly my clock like she
full on said what you're saying
and then boom 30 years old that happens
they get married very quick people think
that it was for tv it was for show they
were full on dating like it was a real
thing
and i then i think over time she
realized oh this probably isn't for me
he's more of a midwestern guy i'm an la
girl i'm not changing he's not changing
it didn't work out but she point blank
what says i'm 30 and i'm very worried
about settling down and having kids and
all that stuff like that and that's when
kanye stepped in
after everything exactly it's ten years
ago that's when kanye stepped in and
they got married and had kids
immediately for call and then obviously
that's that's worked out but and now
what is she doing living her life no
being young she's 40 21 years old she's
banging freaking pete davidson
the least settle down guy out there
right because she she's feeling like
she's but that's the reason
listen i come from a spanish culture
where you're like i thought i was going
to be
married by 23 having kids by 24. really
you know yeah cuban culture yeah like
yeah just like latinos like that's you
you get married you have kids and you
live your life right but living
limitlessly living limitlessly baby you
know what
but we have like so many people are
having kids and in marriage isn't
unhappy right so why are you gonna birth
a kid if you know that you can't take
care of the kid or you still have trauma
that you haven't dealt with now the kid
is coming out with trauma like people
are thinking
sometimes when you you think oh i have
to get married and i have to have kids
by this age because that's what society
tells me no you do what your body tells
you what you feel like you need to do
you can't keep living by every day the
metrics are changing every day
you